yay that's it that's it we're done
[Laughter]
hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey I'm Rand Gendler but I'm not a
real region region your guests to guess
the check up dude
honorary reject honored that for today
video podcast time I figured who better
to join us here than this movies herself
because she has a lot of podcasting
experience and we got some touchy
subjects we're gonna talk about and this
video today is gonna be a fun one it's
actually requested because one of our
top of war tears bran on patreon patron
I'm familiar you're familiar you used to
help run something like that I did is
whatever video you requested was
definitely doing put up on YouTube and
every once in a while we get a
discussion based one and today is a
discussion based one it comes from Eric
horseman he's the guy who got that real
rejects tattoo Wow
hashtag hopefully no regrets which fun
fact that guy from that movie we we
actually used to know Eddie him he has a
fun topic eric is an openly gay man I'll
lead with that I love you Eric well I
would do things with you if I was gay
see that's how you get the gay community
Brienne killer guys gonna learn a thing
or two from this street yeah gay guys um
yeah that's to basically not sure if
this is a topic you want to discuss but
how do you feel about straight actors
playing gay or transgender came to mind
when I write about scars Oh dropping out
of a movie after backlash super planet
transgender character and you know he
goes on and talked about a whole bunch
of different ones basically now that
we're in the 21st century and
homosexuality were accepted he goes on
to talk about [ __ ] you know [ __ ] Trump
I just feel it's time for more gate
transit and transgendered actors to play
these roles and especially because you
know like called me by her name was a
pretty big critical darling and those
are two actors two straight actors plain
gay people and it when I read this
message some things did come to mind
immediately once I read it which what
how come every time straight people play
gay people there's always that thought
that this this thing that goes around or
it's like how how brave of these actors
to do that they're so brave to play gay
people and in some ways I feel like when
we start putting that out there it kind
of has this like negative connotation
towards it of that it's like oh this
could potentially ruin your career by
playing a gay person there's kind of
this like dark thing about it that I
feel like by saying that it's kind of
insulting to a certain degree I don't
know I can't speak for the gay community
but I kind of feel like it is I can John
speak you can do you guys thoughts on
this brand my initial thought is actors
wouldn't be actors if they were only
playing roles that are meant for them
right yeah so like that's their job
their job is to be portraying all
different types of people all different
types of characters all different types
of backgrounds which is kind of weird
when you have the background situation
but they that's their job and I would
love to see more people being considered
for certain roles and I think that's
that's maybe a due diligence on the part
of a studio but at the same time like a
studio has to make money and so they're
gonna be looking for someone that's
going to help make sell their product
like you have to think of it as like I'm
buying a product I am a consumer I am
going to buy a product by going to a
movie like am I going to pick this movie
which I kind of I know about and I know
the people that are involved in it or am
I going to pick this movie where I don't
really know that people but I'm gonna
take a chance on it because I I like
what its presenting to me so I think you
have to think of it from a from like a
product it's a product which
product are you gonna go for mm-hmm and
I think that's the mindset of so you're
talking about just in terms of who they
cast anymore household names or actors
who just happen to be straight the same
reason why when a musical comes to the
screen they don't cast the people that
were in the Broadway musical even though
they we already know that they're
awesome like why aren't they cast like
why isn't the cast of Chicago why
weren't they cast instead of Renee
Zellweger who can't sing and can't dance
like that did that doesn't make sense in
casting to me in terms of someone that
loves the musical Chicago yeah or Pierce
Brosnan Mamma Mia that it was a really
terrible John your initial thoughts I
mean my initial thought on this is
generally speaking yeah I feel like
straight actors shouldn't be precluded
from playing gay or trans characters on
the other hand though I think that we
are in a place now in time where there's
a lot more visibility it's not as taboo
or underground to be gay or transsexual
it's still a hot topic but I feel like
this is indicative of the fact that we
need to start elevating and you know
giving more opportunities to gay and
trans actors because right now yeah it's
like I feel like the landscape ought to
be that just any actor should have a
shot at that role the problem right now
is that there are just so many less gay
and trans actors getting those rules
probably less trans actors getting those
roles and I think right now the issue
for me is a little harder or a little
more you know lucid for the trans
community because they are just on the
verge of being recognized by greater
society more so like we've gave the gay
community in general I feel like has had
a bit more time just in the cultural I
too now it's a little less taboo you
know I think we're still dealing with it
but um but yeah it's like I don't blame
Scarlett Johansson for stepping down I
don't think her signing on to play a
trans character is as nasty as her
signing on to play what should have been
an Asian character because
that's one thing where I'm like okay
yeah I can see how this is kind of yeah
appropriating something in the wrong way
but yeah I don't know in short I don't
think it's bad for straight actors to
play gay or trans people because you
know sexuality is a spectrum and I do I
don't I don't think it's bad for
straight actors to play gay people at
all or transgenders admin actually I've
looked last night for the first time I
watched and this was just by chance I
watched Dallas buyers club for the first
time and Jared Leto's performance in
that who is incredible in that film I
could totally see why I won the Oscar
and there were times where I thought he
was very attractive whose it says
something about me mmm perfect time
we're doing this video I hopefully no I
did tell my girlfriend I thought he was
attractive it's okay it's out there now
so anyway yeah but watching them like
well there's that and I do think though
that there are a lot of openly gay
actors out there now and I think that
more of these roles should be going to
them and I think that's the direction I
would like us to go into there's that
famous quote by Ian McKellen talking
about how no openly gay man has won an
Oscar for acting yet but yet there's
people who win Oscars for playing gay
people and get a lot of awards
recognition for playing gay people and I
think it would be it's like you know
crazy rich Asians came out last year and
so did Black Panther and they didn't get
like the most famous Asian people and
there they didn't get the most famous
black guy to play Black Panther but you
know you just did the right casting and
I feel like more of those opportunities
should be given to gay people as well
like one of one of my dream projects to
see come to life is a movie about it as
an action movie an action hero and he's
gay but we don't put a lot of emphasis
on it you just like he's just gay that's
just the thing about him but he's not
like we're not playing up like
flamboyant qualities they're putting a
lot of emphasis on it it's just a thing
about him and I feel like Wentworth
Miller from Prison Break would be a
perfect choice for that you know I guess
he has that like very hardcore masculine
quality about him in a lot of people
don't even know he's gay but he is and
I'm like that would be cool to see that
happened more in that direction that's
kind of what I would want to see is have
you guys seen Brooklyn nine-nine
I'm not but I've seen clips who's you
know the actor who plays the Andre
Braugher yeah the chief the chief of
police I like that kind of portrayal I
really like two of you know it's it's
it's like yeah his part of his
background is he's gay but you saw like
all this major emphasis on I try to push
a point or agenda because I feel like we
could use a little bit more of that but
if you're also gonna do your movies like
call me by your name or whatever it
would be nice to have more actual you
know openly gay people play those roles
it would be nice I think but I also got
me coming from what's even more
important is the writers room and having
like if you're gonna tell a story about
a homosexual or a transgender person
like I really hope that someone of that
background wrote that story or it was
involved in writing that story instead
of seeing it through the lens of a
straight person that can be you no
problem woman 2 oh yeah the other day I
was writing trivia questions for an
all-black trivia match for movies and I
was like I am a white woman writing with
my friends like it doesn't like these
are not gonna be very authentic like I
need someone to go over these and look
through them and like decide is that
correct or is that not or what are you
even writing so I just I laugh at
certain things like I see you coming up
with the questions for Pootie Tang it's
like do am i picking the like more
whitewashed movies right Cleopatra Jones
questions you get I think it was a good
call for ScarJo to step down from the
from the transgender role specifically I
see like I I don't think it's right to
get it to hating on straight people
though for plain these care for playing
gay people that they're just accepting a
job I think yet exactly less hateable
offense than the
like whitewashing something you know now
I remember her stepping down from
something but I don't know much about
the project you know more about the
project
I don't remember specifically all I know
is the transgender I think just because
there's it's like we work in like these
increments of movements of things
getting more progressive and more
accepting because like it's pretty cool
that there's been a lot more movies that
portray gay people and then now it's
like okay well the next stage now is
what gay people gay people you know just
the next logical step right there yeah
let let members of the community author
of these things cuz I'm not like I said
I can't really speak for the gay
community and but I feel like there's
something kind of strong it with
straight people playing gay people be in
the beginning because that shows a level
of acceptance but I don't know I mean
what do you guys think of that well I've
I mean that's an interesting thought
experiment to me because I don't know
there's so many we still haven't all
gotten on the same page about what
sexual orientation is and how it works
and so I feel like yeah the way people
are able to take on a role slip into the
lifestyle explore that you know do the
physical side of it as well and then
come back out I don't know how well this
helps any of these points but you can
kind of use that as an indicator that
yeah you're not gonna catch the gay or
something like that you know it's not I
feel like I don't know what it says oh
yeah because there's the backwards view
that like all it's a choice or oh you
know it's a it's a kind of genetic
mutation or something there's still
backwards people out there and so I
don't know like the fact that people can
slip in and out and do these roles and
go on with life is kind of indicative of
something yeah well I feel like that's
about as far as we're gonna get on this
topic guys anything else we'd like to UM
I do want to share it there's a great
movie called camp it's I don't know if
you like musical theater but I do and it
had it portrays transgendered kids gay
kids on this camp and they go and they
it's a musical theater camp and they go
and they perform like different bits of
musical theater throughout it and it's
great Anna Kendrick is in it so that's a
familiar face that you'll see but this
came out in early 2000s I want to say
2001 and it was like a festival when
around the festivals and now you can
probably stream it somewhere but mmm
love it
so looking for representation okay don't
know if those actors were transgender
themselves or gay or what-have-you but a
great job well I think there is an
aspect to of they're there as there has
long been at least on the cult side of
cinema you know like gay cinema LGBT
cinema and so that still exists today in
a kind of smaller portion of the market
so you know supporting those movies and
seeking out those stories is also
something that just helps you know
because I feel like the more those
movies do well or get support you know
the more breakout or crossover you know
stars you might see come out of them
because every time you go to a Laemmle
you know you see a wide variety of
different movies different than what
you'd see it in AMC and usually there's
something in there for all the different
walks of life so it's not like there is
no cinema it's just that you know it's
not patronized quite as much as you know
the regular system white mainstream
stuff I get I guess though I mean the
last thing I want to bring up is the
first thing I brought up of I actually I
think I remember Ellen Page it was an
Ellen Page who talked about the thing I
brought up at the beginning because when
I from our first Fred Erik's message to
to me I was I did think about that how a
lot of the times when straight actors
play these gables there's always that
talk of like such bravery for beating a
guy I mean do you kind of wish that
conversation would sort of stop in that
direction it could be I mean the same
could be said for someone playing
someone that's disabled I think what
makes them brave as well right it seems
like what you're truly saying by saying
that is just like oh wow look at that
person doing something so different than
their natural life which yeah I guess
that's what I kind of poorly articulated
before about you know like straight
actors playing gay roles like I don't
think it's
brave or not brave I think it's just an
exploration of another side of life that
you know a lot of people brush with yeah
I mean I'm still on the fence of that I
think the blind community is gonna be
upset that not enough blind people are
playing blind characters
yeah sure daredevil don't breathe
because when these blind people watch
these movies they have like things that
will describe the movie TV they're there
ways for blind people to watch the
movies or to take in a sense because I'm
sorry no blind people are watching if
you're blind please comment below and I
will publicly apologize on undergo all
of you anywho
guys comment below if uh what your
thoughts are on this topic do you want
to see more gay people playing actual
gay people wait do I see actual gay
people playing gay people I mean during
that's how I should say the question
right during the movie I don't want to
think about it while reading the movie
news that is sure good point good point
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification belt and
also Brienne Chandler or can they follow
you Instagram you could follow me miss
underscore movies you can check out my
archive of shows on YouTube at miss
movies there it is there it is guys
thanks for being here Breanna